[Music]
so we are going to rank all of the Star
Wars films canonically but we're gonna
go worst to best worst to best I know we
already know what the best one is but
we'll start worst to best
okay the worst Star Wars film Phantom
Menace charting in at number eleven now
I know a lot of people think Attack of
the Clones goes here you're gonna be
shocked right put Attack of the Clones a
lot of people say last Jedi I hear ya I
hear ya last Jedi is hot garbage
it's a terrible film a truly terrible
film filled with plot holes and
stupidity Phantom Menace however is
worse the reason that Phantom Menace is
worse is because George Lucas makes a
critical error he thinks that the reason
that kids like Star Wars is because they
want to see kids this is one of the big
errors that a lot of people who make
kids films do and Pixar doesn't make
this error by the way Pixar does not
make films exclusively about small
children kids don't actually want to
watch kids kids kind of want to be
adults making Jedi Anakin six years old
is really weird and then making Jedi
Anakin significantly younger than Padme
is super duper weird and becomes even
weirder in the future movies everything
with young Anakin is almost unwatchable
Liam Neeson is fine you and McGregor is
fine they are criminally underused in
this film and the film just is
exorbitant Lee long it's really long I
remember seeing it in the theater being
really excited for it and walking out on
yeah it was it was not an auspicious
beginning to the prequels okay number 10
last Jedi obviously last Jedi is just
flaming Lee bad a flaming Lee bad film
now there could have been a moment where
the film could have gotten good right
there's a moment where ray and kylo look
like they're gonna team up and then it's
gonna radically change the history of
Star Wars that suddenly the dark side in
the light side aren't fighting on the
same side and all of a sudden the
universe changes radically and then Rian
Johnson cuz he's an idiot he has them
separate off again and then you get the
the ridiculous Luke Skywalker hologram
face off with kylo Ren and you and you
get the the idiocy of a film in which
you basically redo the Battle of Hoth
except you make it on a salt planet and
then you say it's a salt planet ten
times the people don't think that it's
just the ice Battle of Hoth all over
again when it's obviously just the Ice
Battle of Hoth all over again
it totally should've killed Finn they
totally should have killed the the
what's the name of the the person
everyone forgets Rose everyone
understands they should have killed Rose
that would have at least given it some
stakes the last Jedi totally destroys
Luke Skywalker's character and this is
one of the problems as we will see when
we get to to the next one one of the
problems with the new trilogy is that it
is based on destroying all of your old
characters number 9 force awakens again
people gonna think this is controversial
it is not controversial force awakens is
a bad film the reason it is a bad film
is not because on its own it is such a
bad film the reason is because it takes
all of your old characters and just
murders them in front of your eyes
literally murders them it takes all the
characters you grew up with and loved
and who made your childhood han Solo and
turns Han Solo into a loser divorced and
flying around the universe like Cheech
and Chong smoking dope in the in the
Millennium Falcon and then has him
murdered at the hands of his own son
because Leia is too chicken to go
confronts her own son now as you will
see again you're gonna be shocked by
where I rank rise of Skywalker JJ Abrams
does try to fix this with some lens
flare in her eyes of Skywalker but the
fact is that force awakens is a is a
criminal act against the Star Wars
legacy they decided they were gonna kill
off all of the olds in order to build
characters who are significantly less
interesting than the old characters in
the first place and kill off your
childhood in the process I could not
hate force awakens more than I hate
force awakens I watched out of the
theater I thought okay that was alright
and then every waking moment since then
I've thought about force awakens I've
gotten angrier at force awakens and so
it ranks in among me among the worst of
the Star Wars films number eight Attack
of the Clones now everybody hates attack
of the clones I've heard people say
attack of the clones is the worst of the
of the prequels it is not the worst
through the prequels Phantom Menace is a
worse film than Attack of the Clones
why because Christopher Lee is great and
Count Dooku's character is poorly
written account Dooku is this is the
secret hero of the of these Star Wars
prequels Count Dooku is not wrong
he is a separatist from a Senate and has
been taken over secretly by a Sith Lord
he's the only one who knows this and he
has set off to move on outside of a of a
Trade Federation that is instituting
tariffs against planets he doesn't wish
to see tariffs he's a free trade
libertarian Count Dooku beyond that he
has a pretty good lightsaber battle with
both you and McGregor and Yoda the the
basic plotting of it is more interesting
than Phantom Menace now it does have
some of the worst romance
in history of film writing everything
involving Hayden Christensen and Natalie
Portman it's a horror show it's death
you are smoother than sand milady is one
of the worst lines in the history
I hate sad it's costing oh my god oh my
god it is that film that more than any
really destroyed my perception of
Natalie Portman as a decent actress I
still think that she is wildly overrated
but with that said is it better than
Phantom Menace yes because at least you
start to get flashes of what's gonna
happen in Revenge of the Sith which has
we will see actually is a pretty good
movie okay number seven so here we move
on into the movies that are wat that are
watchable right we've now moved into the
the arena of movies that you would
rewatch if you saw them beginning on TNT
right where you're flipping through and
you see a scene you need to watch it
right if you're flipping through you see
something from force awakens like nope
you see something from Phantom Menace
you're like double nope something from
attackin declined saying hey hey is he
something from solo maybe you'll stop
now I know a lot of people are down on
solo I'm not sure why I think solo is
amusing it's it's kind of fun it doesn't
sell out Han Solo's character the way
that the the sequels do right the
sequels actually destroy Han Solo's
character they turned him from his whole
his whole hero's journey in the original
Star Wars Han Solo is from rogue who
only cares about himself and is a
mercenary to self-sacrificing general in
the resistance who's going to get
married at the end and have little Jedi
babies with Leia right that's that is
his his hero's journey and then they
completely revert him back to rogue who
only cares about himself in in the in
the sequels Solo doesn't do that Solo is
is starting that journey
the problem with Solo is that it sort of
gives him the hero's journey before the
hero's journey he has to start off with
being this dissolute rogue who is is
cynical and nasty right that has to be
the hero's journey beginning in Episode
four so the proceeds that he already has
some of these towards the rebellion he
already is showing some aspects of
self-sacrifice which it which is kind of
weird that's the problem with Solo also
I will say that the Kessel run is
completely missed on if you take a
shortcut in the Kessel run it doesn't
count as you doing in less than 12
parsecs but it's got some amusing
moments the robot in solo is one of the
better robots and one is one of the
better droids and all of Star Wars
so Solo ranks at number seven rise of
Skywalker at number six
so people hated rise of sky
because they are wrong rise of Skywalker
has half of the movie is just throw away
nonsense right the very beginning where
you have the the Millennium Falcon hop
hopping and skipping planet to planet is
really dumb and useless and very JJ
Abrams the part of it that's good is
that it actually goes back to respecting
the legacy of Star Wars because remember
force awakens killed off Han Solo for no
apparent reason in order to kill off the
old snake room for the new West Jedi
then decided to go even further and kill
off Luke Skywalker as a good character
and then kill off the idea the Skywalker
family matters at all because apparently
random kids just get the force and which
undercuts the entire trilogy rise of
Skywalker retcons basically rise of
Skywalker is what if I just crap all
over Rian Johnson and I'm all for it man
I am there for it basically it is we're
gonna retcon this entire history we're
going to shoehorn leia into she was
actually a jedi we're going to retcon
Luke into why are you throwing why
aren't you respecting each eyed
traditions no burning of Jedi books no
throwing away of lightsabers
why aren't you respecting Jedi
traditions we retcon Han Solo in - yeah
he's a hero who cared about his son and
was willing to self-sacrifice we reckon
to everything we reckon everything and
we make the biggest retcon of all which
is the most important one which is that
rey is actually Palpatine's
granddaughter know naturally Disney
screwed this up and they tried to retcon
the retcon afterward right they tried to
suggest that that Palpatine was actually
a clone Palpatine he wasn't actually
Palpatine okay I understand Palpatine
died at the end of Return of the Jedi I
also understand whatever man
okay whatever it's got actually be
Palpatine if this is to have any meeting
at all but it makes sense that she's
Palpatine's granddaughter because the
most powerful force being in the galaxy
is indeed Emperor Palpatine
so for her to do that it completely
solves the maryjane problem which was a
huge problem in force awakens that she
picks up a lightsaber and suddenly she's
fighting Ben solo who's been training
for 20 years and has skywalker blood
right now she's like well no I'm a
Palpatine kid he's wounded I'm a
Palpatine kid
check this out right like okay got it
that makes sense now that makes sense
they bring back all the old music from a
turn of the Jedi which is great they
bring back all of a lot of the old
scenery from the turn of the Jedi which
is just fantastic they allow Han a
better goodbye which was necessary
because the way they killed him in force
awakens is disrespectful
they allowed Luke a better goodbye by
having him force raised from the grave
the x-wing in the same way that Yoda did
which is really
like as opposed to the idiotic way they
got rid of him in last Jedi where he
basically joe biden's it right means you
sort of like plotz's and disappears of
old age and then just so you could have
that shot of the two sons like tattooing
oh I see the parallelism Rian Johnson
okay so rise of Skywalker comes in at
number six because it actually respects
the tradition and you get points for
that number five Return of the Jedi so
return to the Jedi I would take two
thirds of this movie is fantastic and
one third of it is so everything that is
Luke and Darth Vader related is just
great
the final throne room stuff is just
fantastic all of that is great it has
great music the the dynamic between
Palpatine in mcdermott is fantastic the
dynamic between Palpatine and Darth
Vader and Luke is the best thing about
the movie han becoming a more
responsible human being is good the
entire speeder scene is actually a very
cool scene on Endor the the second Death
Star and in the plot to trap the rebels
is good even Lando flying the the
Millennium Falcon make some sense the
Ewoks are not great the the space battle
doesn't seem to have tremendous
consequences it's obviously not as
impactful as the as the new hope space
battle but in concluding the trilogy
it's good also the job of stuff at the
beginning there's a great threat I sent
from a friend of mine Frank Fleming
online where he completely deconstructs
the job and stuff a bit like what was
Luke's actual plan so his plan was I'm
gonna send the droids in and then do
they get kept by Java or do they not
like if it he'd have to then rescue the
droids right because if job had kept the
droids know hey here's Han when they've
just left artoo and c3po there no so he
has Lando in there under cover Lando
never actually does anything undercover
then he sends in the droids to be
captured from no apparent reason then he
sends in Leia to make the trade with
Jabba for Han but now he still has to
rescue c-3po and r2 then he shows up but
he doesn't actually just brandish the
lightsaber and tell Jabba he's gonna
blow him away like kill him unless he
releases all of his friends he proceeded
to be thrown into a rancor pit which
presumably Lando knew about could have
warned him about like the beginning
makes no sense it's fun but it makes no
sense
with that said Return of the Jedi that
the the conclusion of the trilogy is
very moving and it definitely works
Revenge of the Sith is number four now
Revenge of the Sith I rewatched it
recently it's good it's a good movie
Revenge of the Sith the last two-thirds
of it is really good everything for an
Palpatine becomes overtly maniacal to
the end or
66 that whole sequence is very effective
where you're saying all of these Jedi
gets shot down and killed all of that is
really effective the the Hayden
Christensen turn at the end is good it
actually works emotionally when you and
McGregor is upset about all this
now Hayden Christensen still can't that
but that's just the wages of sin it's
good there's a lot in Revenge of the
Sith that's great the the final
lightsaber battle is excellent the big
flaw in Revenge of the Sith is that the
the sort of rationale for why Darth
Vader becomes Darth Vader doesn't really
work too well because the question
becomes why he still works for the
Emperor afterward right because he
apparently falls to the dark side
because he wants the power to be able to
say Padma okay Padme dies so why is he
still hanging out at the Emperor at that
point they ever made him a promise the
Emperor didn't fulfill the promise also
we all know that thus if the princess
tries to kill the the Sith master so why
doesn't he just try and kill Palpatine
like right away and take control of the
galaxy if that's really what he's up to
it's weird that he becomes sort of a
functionary in the Galactic regime of
Palpatine after it turns out that his
wife died and Palpatine didn't do
anything to to save him to save her
number three I'm gonna go off the board
you ready for this one row one yeah I
know a lot of people want to put Revenge
of the Sith or ro TJ Return of the Jedi
on this list at this point I go rogue
one I think rogue one is an actually
really well made film a road one is
fascinating it has just enough tips of
the hats of the original Star Wars
trilogy to draw you in also the ending
of it is shocking right this is one of
the new Star Wars films and one of the
original kind of Star Wars recognitions
is that nobody who's a major character
except Alec Guinness dies in the first
three Star Wars not a single major
character who's a who's a hero dies in
the first three Star Wars at least not
of old age I mean
Yoda dies of old age but rogue one kills
off all the main characters at the end
which is a shock
I remember watching this in the theater
for the first time I said what what did
what did they just do they just set you
up with all of these characters who
actually like and then they kill all of
them somebody described I'm in front of
them at the time they were kind of right
they described rogue one as an actual
war film as in not just Star Wars but
natural war film and that's right I mean
this is about human sacrifice and what
people are willing to do in order to
accomplish a mission including giving up
your life if you're in this case you
know probably 25 years old as the
heroes of the plot are so Roblin is
really that also that that final the
final scene where Darth Vader finally
lets loose is just ridiculously good and
if you ever watch the mashup of the end
of rogue one and the beginning of new
hope it's fantastic it's fantastic they
just take the very end of rogue one
where Darth Vader is just cutting a
swath of people and in the beginning of
the episode of Episode four where Darth
Vader catches its hands hit four and
they just match it up and it works
perfectly it's beautiful number two is a
new host and there's some controversy
over that a new hope should go in front
of Empire the only reason being that
Empire wouldn't exist without new hope
but new hope is in and of itself a very
good movie now I know these movies hold
up because I've shown them to my six in
my three year old and they love them I
mean they are into them I've shown them
some of the new movies not as much a new
hope is is fantastic it's creative it's
interesting it obviously follows all the
beats in Joseph Campbell so it is
famously reflective of Joseph Campbell's
hero's journey it's got some some of the
best lines in movie history stuff that
everybody quotes all the time it's got
great legit actors like Alec Guinness
alongside newcomers like Harrison Ford
the initial opening is so good I
actually used the initial opening as an
explanation of how politics ought to
work in a campaign because the initial
opening is all Darth Vader right you
don't meet Luke for the first like 20
minutes of the film basically the first
15 minutes of the film and that's
because you first have to establish the
bad guys before you establish the good
guys it's a good lesson for people who
are running in politics if you ever want
to run a political campaign first
establish who your opponent is and then
it makes it easier to establish who you
are and finally as you all know number
one this is not a question this is not a
theory this is not an opinion it is a
simple fact Empire Strikes Back is the
best of the Star Wars movies and one of
the best movies of all time my father
assures me the woman people saw this in
the theaters they literally could not
believe they had to wait until Return of
the Jedi came out for confirmation that
Darth Vader was telling the truth people
doubted it even after watching Empire
Strikes Back it's a brilliant movie one
of the things that's great about the
movies it's really about how Han Solo is
competent and one of the things that
that Disney has done with the Star Wars
universe that's really stupid is they've
decided that basically all the male
characters are radically incompetent in
the original Star Wars pretty much
everybody's good at their job right
Princess Leia is competent Han Solo is
competent Luke Skywalker is increasingly
competent Darth Vader is competent it's
a bunch of competent people you know
what makes for interesting plots calm
people and part of strikes back is all
about how Han Solo is shockingly
competent and all the things he's
attempting to do how he's a rogue and
the writing is fantastic Lawrence Kasdan
does a beautiful job with the script
also everything Yoda related is just
tremendous and of course it has a
phenomenal phenomenal score from John
Williams Empire Strikes Back obviously
number one on the list with a bullet I
mean it is just it is not close already
well may the fourth be with you and an
honor of may the fourth tonight we have
an all-access live we'll be discussing
all this to be part of the all-access
live you have to actually become a
member over at daily wire.com slash
subscribe but will become an all-access
member you get 25% off 1/4 off get it
1/4 may the fourth you get it you gotta
get it all you have to do is use promo
code Empire because it is indeed the
greatest of all the Star Wars films now
we'll see on all-access live a little
bit later daily we're calm slash
subscribe
you